arizona attorney general now senate
candidate who from the great state of
arizona mark brnovich is with us and the
president of the national border patrol
council brandon judd brandon let's deal
with the crisis a created by joe biden
he's the one that overturned the
successful policies of donald trump
that was his decision his borders are
doesn't go to the border
now they've taken away horseback and
they're making accusations of racism and
i have talked to person after person
after person and every border patrol
agent that i have talked to says that is
called a rain and there was no whipping
of people uh and they are furious and
feel that this is being used as a
distraction that's what my sources tell
me what are you hearing from your rank
and file
i've been patrolling the borders uh
since clinton was the president and i
can tell you personally
that the policies that have been in
place were by far the best under
president trump and and president biden
completely and totally dismantled all of
those policies and when you look at our
border patrol agents when they are sent
down there to do that job and by the way
maiorkus was down on the border and he
saw the horses he knew the horses were
out there and now he's making doing a
180. but when our agents are out there
trying to patrol the border do their job
to the best of their ability then
they're vilified by the president you
know we feel like why even go out there
and do it why put on that uniform why
care about the american public that's
why we do it we put on that uniform
because we care about the american
public we want to go out there and we
want to protect them and joe biden is
trying to break that down and there's
been a high rate of covet positivity
overcrowded cages the middle of a
pandemic no testing no vaccine mandates
attorney general brnovich we've had greg
abbott on the program he's now got miles
long borders of cars because that's the
only thing at his disposal
he's called up the national guard but
then there's a legal issue of who gets
control and whether or not joe biden can
take control of that
legally you have been successful in
going up against the biden
administration legally what are the
options available for border states like
yours and and
texas well thank you sean for having me
on and as you mentioned we have had
multiple lawsuits against the bidet
administration and what's so frustrating
to us that i've been a prosecutor much
my career is the fact that they won't
even follow the existing law the
president is at apex apex of his power
when it comes to national security and
border security and yet he literally
turned over afghanistan to the taliban
and now he's seeding control the border
to the cartels and so the federal
government biden's trying to mandate a
vaccine which we've sued him over and
yet he won't secure the border which is
part of his duties and responsibilities
and so you know i've been using the
tools in my toolbox that includes
litigation trying to force him to build
the wall trying to make sure that he
reinstates the or reinstate the
remaining mexico policy
making sure that people that have
deportation orders are deported not
because we're a cruel nation but because
that's what the law requires let me ask
you the legal question because you've
been a big supporter of president
trump's and his policies worked we were
at a 25-year low we're now going to have
a 25-30 year hot record high of illegal
immigrants crossing the border
from
a legal standpoint is joe biden aiding
and abetting law breaking
and didn't he take an oath not to do
that
well clearly he's violating his oath to
protect
the republican form of government the
united states and you know arguably i'm
sure there's some folks that probably
think this is the equivalent of an
invasion and so we're doing weekend
legally but when it comes to aiding and
abetting you know the president has a
lot of authority when it comes to the
border this is what he's
constitutionally charged to do he
doesn't have the authority to mandate
vaccines but he does have the authority
to enforce our laws especially at the
border well he's not doing it
i know it's dangerous sean
well that's called aiding and embedding
uh we only have 15 seconds brandon um
high rate of covert positivity
how many agents do you know of that have
contracted covert working at the border
we only have 10 seconds
we have hundreds out every single day
because of this but let me let me put it
this way if president biden wasn't the
president right now i would arrest him
for aiding and abetting
wow thank you both hey sean hannity here
hey click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else